>> PREVIOUSLY ON
>> AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
>> THE GIRLS HIT THE PAVEMENT
IN BARCELONA
TO IMPRESS THE LOCAL DESIGNERS.
>> AMANDA--SHE'S MUCH BETTER
THAN HER SISTER.
(bull snorts)
>> A HIGH-RISK PHOTO SHOOT
BROUGHT OUT THE BEST
IN EUGENA AND MICHELLE...
>> THAT IS GENIUS.
>> BUT MICHELLE'S
LINGERING DOUBTS
PROVED TO BE HER UNDOING.
>> I DON'T THINK
I'M THE STRONGEST
IN THIS COMPETITION.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I WANT.
>> THE TWINS
STOOD SIDE BY SIDE...
AMANDA.
BUT MICHELLE WAS SENT HOME.
FOUR GIRLS REMAIN--
EUGENA, CARIDEE,
MELROSE AND AMANDA.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
>> ♪ YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP? ♪
♪♪
>> CARIDEE, HELP A SISTER OUT.
>> THAT IS SO CUTE!
>> DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING-- PINK OR PURPLE?
YEAH?
>> YES.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S ADORABLE.
>> I FRICKIN' LOVE THAT.
>> OH, YEAH, THAT IS--
IF THAT'S NOT BARCELONA,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS.
>> UH, I DON'T KNOW.
AT THE LAST PANEL,
THE BOTTOM TWO WAS
ME AND MY TWIN SISTER MICHELLE.
MICHELLE WENT HOME BECAUSE
WHEN THEY ASKED HER
WHO SHE THOUGHT
THE WEAKEST PERSON WAS,
SHE SAID HERSELF.
>> I STILL DON'T KNOW
WHAT I WANT.
LIKE, I SEE OTHER GIRLS, LIKE--
LIKE, THEY WANT THIS SO BADLY.
>> IT WAS HER OWN CHOICE
TO TELL THEM HOW SHE FELT,
BUT IT STILL FELT LIKE,
IF YOU WOULDN'T HAVE SAID THAT,
YOU'D STILL BE HERE,
BUT WOULD I?
>> AMANDA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> IT KINDA FELT LIKE
SHE MADE A SACRIFICE FOR ME.
TWIN!
>> (laughs)
>> I LOVE YOUR SISTER.
MICHELLE KNOWS THAT
AMANDA REALLY WANTS THIS,
SO I KNOW SHE'D RATHER
HAVE HER SISTER STAY.
GOD, SHE'S AMAZING--YOUR SISTER.
>> I KNOW.
>> BECAUSE THAT'S JUST
THE WONDERFUL PERSON
THAT SHE IS.
>> THIS IS REALLY WEIRD,
HAVING MY OWN ROOM.
>> YEAH?
>> I'M VERY--
>> COME CUDDLE
IF YOU EVER GET LONELY.
>> I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE.
I'M SAD TO SEE HER GO.
I DON'T KNOW IF I SHOULD'VE
BEEN THE ONE TO GO, SO I'M LIKE,
DID THEY MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISION?
IS SHE GONNA BE OKAY?
THANK YOU, MICHELLE.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> OKAY.
"IN THE MODELING INDUSTRY,
WORKING WITH A PARTNER
HAS MANY PROS.
YOU JUST HAVE TO KEEP THEM
FROM STEPPING ON YOUR TOES.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> MAYBE A PHOTO SHOOT, UM...
♪♪
>> GO.
>> OH!
♪♪
>> (speaking Spanish)
>> HE'S, UH, NACHO.
HE'S A TEACHER.
FLAMENCO TEACHER.
>> Sí.
>> WE ARRIVED
AT THE DANCE STUDIO,
AND THERE'S A REALLY SHORT GUY
WAITING FOR US--
NACHO AND HIS TRANSLATOR.
>> ...BUT SOMETIMES
YOU ALSO HAVE TO WORK
WITH PARTNERS,
SO IN THE FLAMENCO WORLD TODAY,
HE'S GONNA TEACH YOU
HOW TO WORK WITH A PARTNER.
>> THEY SAID,
"YOU'LL HAVE A PARTNER,"
AND SO THESE FOUR GUYS
COME OUT, AND THEY DANCE.
>> OH!
>> (laughs) AGAIN.
>> THE IDEA OF DANCING
JUST MAKES ME REALLY NERVOUS,
BECAUSE I'M NOT
A VERY STRONG DANCER.
>> (speaking Spanish)
>> WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IN THE FIRST PLACE,
HE'S GONNA TEACH YOU SOME STEPS.
>> (speaking Spanish)
(chanting rhythmically)
>> IT WAS EASY FOR ME
BECAUSE I DO HAVE RHYTHM,
AND I USED TO DANCE
JAZZ AND BALLET.
>> DOES HE PUT THIS BACK AGAIN?
>> THE ONE THAT'S IN FRONT
GOES FORWARD.
>> UNO, DOS Y TRES.
(chanting rhythmically)
>> WHEN I MESS UP
THE FIRST FEW STEPS,
I HAVE TO START OVER,
WHICH IS REALLY BAD.
>> BRAZOS ARRIBA.
>> (laughs)
>> AMANDA LOOKS LIKE
AMANDA TRYING TO DANCE.
AMANDA LOOKS AWKWARD AS USUAL.
>> (speaking Spanish)
>> (laughs)
>> I FORGET. I CAN'T--
DAMN IT.
>> AMANDA IS SO CUTE
TRYING TO DANCE.
THE GIRL HAS TWO LEFT FEET,
BUT YOU CAN TELL
THAT SHE'S TRYING.
>> I'M SORRY.
I'M NOT A QUICK LEARNER.
>> (chanting rhythmically)
>> (speaking Spanish)
>> HAVE YOU DONE
SOME FLAMENCO BEFORE?
>> NO.
>> GOOD JOB.
>> GRACIAS.
>> (speaking Spanish)
>> I'M PRETTY SURE
I LOOKED ALL STIFF AND AWKWARD.
I WISH I COULD SEE MICHELLE
DO THAT, 'CAUSE I THINK
SHE WOULD'VE DONE WORSE THAN ME.
>> I THINK THAT
I LEARNED TO DANCE THE FASTEST.
I THINK I CAME OUT ON TOP TODAY.
>> THE DANCE HAS
A LOT OF FOOTWORK,
AND--AND I DEFINITELY
DID NOT KNOW WHAT I WAS DOING.
♪♪
>> RESERVADO.
THAT MEANS WE HAVE A GUEST,
I DO DECLARE.
>> MISS J.!
>> AH!
>> HOLA.
>> HEY, MISS J.!
>> I WAS EXCITED TO SEE MISS J.
JOIN US FOR DINNER
BECAUSE HE IS ON PANEL,
AND I FELT LIKE
I JUST HAVEN'T REALLY BEEN ABLE
TO JUST HAVE, LIKE,
A LITTLE PERSONAL CHITCHAT
WITH J.
>> THERE'S LOTS TO TALK ABOUT!
>> (laughs)
>> QUESTIONS THAT I WANNA--
THINGS I WANNA KNOW...
THINGS THAT
I'D DIE TO SAY AT JUDGING
AND I NEVER GET A CHANCE TO.
HOW'S EVERYTHING GOING SO FAR?
>> GOOD.
>> YOU GIRLS ARE GETTING
A CRASH COURSE
LIKE YOU WOULD NOT BELIEVE
IN THIS BUSINESS,
AND MANY, MANY, MANY GIRLS
WOULD LOVE TO BE
IN YOUR POSITION.
>> YEP.
>> SO HOW'D YOU END UP
IN THIS COMPETITION?
>> I JUST SAW IT
ON THE WEB SITE.
>> I STUDIED FASHION DESIGN,
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED WAS
I WAS IN LOVE WITH CLOTHES
WHEN I WAS A KID,
AND I COULDN'T FIT IN ANYTHING.
SO MY MOM AND GRANDMOTHER
WERE BOTH SEAMSTRESSES...
>> MELROSE HAS
THREE DIFFERENT PERSONALITIES,
AND SHE'S REALLY GOOD AT IT.
IT'S REALLY CONVINCING.
I MEAN, SHE'S MANIPULATIVE.
SHE CAN, LIKE, BE REALLY COOL.
BUT, YOU KNOW,
IT'S KINDA CREEPY.
>> I STARTED MAKING
MY OWN CLOTHES
'CAUSE I COULDN'T FIT
INTO ANY OF THE CLOTHES.
I WAS TOO SKINNY AND TOO TALL.
>> MAYBE SHE
SHOULD BE MEDICATED.
>> OKAY,
SO YOU'RE THE LUCKY FOUR.
I MEAN, A LOT OF IT
IS HARD WORK,
A LOT OF IT IS A BIT OF LUCK,
AND, YOU KNOW, HERE YOU ARE.
MELROSE, I GUESS YOU REMIND ME
OF THOSE CALENDAR GIRLS.
YOU KNOW, THOSE GIRLS
WHO WANNA DO CALENDAR PINUPS,
YOU KNOW, AND CAR MODELING.
>> IT'S INTENSE
BEING IN THE FINAL FOUR,
BUT I FEEL LIKE A PRO,
AND I'M READY TO WIN.
>> THE TWINS--THESE ARE
THE TWO GOOFIEST GUMBY GIRLS.
(laughter)
>> NOW THAT MICHELLE'S GONE,
I THINK THE COMPETITION
HAS CHANGED FOR ME
BECAUSE I'VE NEVER
DONE ANYTHING BY MYSELF.
I REALLY WANNA BE AN INDIVIDUAL.
>> HERE'S TO
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL-ETTE.
MAY THE BEST BITCH WIN.
>> THE NUMBERS ARE
GOING DOWN--FOUR--
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING...
(imitates Tyra)
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪
>> (gasps)
TYRA MAIL.
"HEAD UP, SHOULDERS BACK.
IT'S GOING TO BE
A STIFF COMPETITION.
LOVE, TYRA."
PHOTO SHOOT TOMORROW.
>> MIGHT NOT.
>> A WHOLE TWIST.
DON'T BE FOOLED.
>> I KNOW MY BODY
AND I KNOW MY MIND,
AND I KNOW, LIKE,
WHEN I DANCE, I CAN DO IT.
I JUST HAVE TO GET
REALLY COMFORTABLE
SO I'M NOT OVERTHINKING IT
WHEN IT COMES TO DANCING.
I BEING, LIKE, HIP-HOPPY ON IT.
I DON'T MEAN TO.
ALL RIGHT. YEAH.
>> I PLAN ON PRACTICING
QUITE A BIT TONIGHT
BECAUSE I THINK I NEED IT,
AND WHEN I DO DANCE
I OFTEN FORGET CERTAIN STEPS.
>> I'M 100% CONFIDENT
THAT I'M GOING TO SHINE.
I DON'T WANNA OVERPRACTICE.
REALLY, ONCE YOU START DANCING,
IT--YOU--IT JUST KIND OF WORKS.
♪♪
>> (laughs)
>> AS WE LOSE MORE GIRLS
IN THIS COMPETITION,
I GET MORE NERVOUS BECAUSE
IT'S JUST TOUGHER AND TOUGHER.
I DEFINITELY WANT TO STAY.
I DON'T WANNA GO HOME.
I WANNA WIN THIS.
IT'S FOR MICHELLE.
♪♪
>> WOW.
>> I KNOW.
I USED A BRAND-NEW RAZOR.
WAIT, WAIT, THIS ONE'S BETTER.
OKAY, GO AHEAD.
EUGENA IS A TRUE, REAL PERSON.
SHE LISTENS, SHE TALKS...
BESIDES THE COMPETITION,
SHE'S GENUINELY CONCERNED.
OKAY, I'LL SHOW YOU MY DANCE.
♪♪
>> (laughs) LOOK AT THIS!
BUT DID I DO GOOD?
>> YOU DID DO IT.
>> I PRACTICED.
ARE YOU SCARED ABOUT IT?
YOU'RE KINDA LIKE, "OH, DAMN."
>> OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS,
CARIDEE AND I STARTED TO BOND
REALLY CLOSELY.
>> I WOULD LIKE IT
TO BE US TWO AT THE END.
>> YEAH, I KNOW.
>> FOR REAL, THOUGH,
BECAUSE IF YOU WIN, LIKE,
I WOULD BE, LIKE, MAD,
BUT I'D BE LIKE...
>> YEAH, I'D BE PISSED OFF
IF SHE WON.
>> (scoffs)
YOU TALKING ABOUT MELROSE?
YEAH.
>> MELROSE.
>> MELROSE--UGH, SHE'S SO FAKE.
MAN, SHE'S LIKE
W.W.F. WRESTLING.
LIKE, THEY PERFORM WELL BUT IT--
THERE'S REALLY NOTHING THERE.
>> IF ONE GIRL
IS GETTING ON MY NERVES
THE MOST IN THIS COMPETITION--
I WOULD SAY CARIDEE.
I'M NOT GONNA BE MEAN,
BUT SHE HAS NO PROBLEM
WITH VULGARITY.
>> (laughs)
>> DID YOU JUST REMOVE THAT FROM
YOUR ASS FROM THE LAST PANEL?
>> OH!
>> IT'S PRETTY GROSS,
BUT I'M HERE TO WIN
A COMPETITION.
I'M HERE TO COMPETE.
I DEFINITELY AM NOT INTERESTED
IN HAVING A FRIENDSHIP
WITH ANYONE.
>> WITH ME AND HER, THOUGH,
IT'S LIKE, WE'LL SMILE
IN EACH OTHER'S FACE,
BUT WE BOTH KNOW
THAT WE DON'T LIKE EACH OTHER.
>> YOU KNOW,
KEEP YOUR FRIENDS CLOSE
BUT YOUR ENEMIES CLOSER.
I DON'T RESPECT MELROSE,
THEREFORE,
THERE IS NO FRIENDSHIP.
IF MELROSE BECOMES
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
I'M GOING TO PUKE...
ALL OVER
I'LL JUST PUKE.
>> OLé!
(singsong voice) OLé, OLé, OLé!
♪♪
>> HOLA, CHICAS.
>> HELLO, LADIES.
TODAY IS A BIG DAY.
>> THE THING THAT
HE'S GONNA LOOK AT THE MOST IS
THE WORK WITH YOUR PARTNER.
(speaking spanish)
(interpreting) LADIES,
I'VE MET YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER,
AND SHE'S GONNA MAKE PICTURES
OF EVERY POSE YOU HAVE.
>> OKAY, LET'S GO
FOR HAIR AND MAKEUP.
>> GRACIAS!
>> GO.
>> HOLA!
>> HELLO.
>> WE HAD TO GET IN, LIKE,
COMPLETE FLAMENCO COSTUME
AND EVERYTHING LIKE THAT.
>> LOOK AT THAT!
THAT'S SO YOUR COLOR.
WHY DON'T YOU WEAR THAT TO PROM?
>> (laughs)
>> I DID WEAR THIS TO PROM.
>> SEE, I DON'T THINK
I WOULD BE SO NERVOUS.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU WANT IT
YOU DON'T GET IT
'CAUSE YOU PSYCH YOURSELF OUT.
>> UH, HOW ARE THEY GONNA SEE
MY FOOTWORK?
THIS IS HUGE ON ME.
>> HEY!
>> AY!
>> HOLA, CHICAS.
>> (speaking Spanish)
>> REALLY PRETTY.
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA DANCE
ONE BY ONE WITH YOUR PARTNERS.
>> (speaking Spanish)
...CARIDEE Y JOSé.
♪♪
>> MY STRATEGY IS JUST
TO FOLLOW MY PARTNER,
AND AS LONG AS I FOLLOW HIM,
I'LL BE ALL RIGHT.
HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S DOING.
>> EVERYONE LOOKS BETTER
THAN THEY DID LAST NIGHT,
AND I FEEL LIKE
I'VE GOT THE FOOTWORK DOWN.
I'M FEELING PRETTY CONFIDENT.
>> I GET INTO THE FIRST STEP,
AND HE GOES WITH HIS ARMS
A LITTLE BIT SOONER
THAN I THOUGHT,
AND I KINDA JUST BLANKED,
KINDA FIBBED IT A LITTLE BIT...
BUT I DEFINITELY MESSED UP
THE FIRST PART OF THE DANCE.
♪♪
>> BRAVO.
>> WELL, HE'S REALLY PROUD
OF YOU, OF ALL OF YOU.
>>AMANDA...
>> HE SAYS YOU'RE MORE RELAXED
AND BETTER.
>> CARIDEE...
>> HE REALLY LIKED THE WORK--
PARTNER WORK YOU GUYS HAD.
>>MELROSE...
>> Sí.
>> HE LIKED OF YOU
THE--YOUR ATTITUDE,
YOUR FACE EXPRESSION...
>> EUGENA...
>> TECHNICALLY,
IT WAS REALLY GOOD.
THE FACE EXPRESSION,
ATTITUDE--IT WAS GOOD AS WELL.
HE LIKES EVERYBODY.
THE JOBS YOU GUYS DID,
IT WAS REALLY GOOD,
BUT HE HAS TO CHOOSE ONE.
>> (speaking Spanish)
...EUGENA.
>> AND NOW YOU GET TO PICK
ONE OF YOUR FRIENDS
TO COME UP HERE WITH YOU.
>> UM, I PICK AMANDA.
>> AMANDA.
>> YAY.
>> I WOULD'VE PICKED
AMANDA, TOO, IF I WOULD'VE WON.
AMANDA HASN'T WON YET,
SO I'D LIKE FOR HER
TO FEEL SPECIAL.
>> OH, WOW.
>> (chuckles)
>> YOU WILL GET TWO
AND SHE WILL--SHE WILL GET ONE.
>> AND... GRACIAS.
>> GRACIAS.
>> YOU STILL DID GOOD UP THERE,
BUT YOU DIDN'T--
YOU DIDN'T MESS UP.
>> NO, I JUST--I MESSED UP
ON THE FIRST STEP.
I HAVE TO START OVER,
AND YOU CAN'T.
I DON'T LIKE DANCING
TO BE SO SERIOUS.
I-I DON'T LIKE THIS AT ALL.
>> I DID MESS UP UP THERE.
LIKE, I PULLED MY ANKLE
ON THE CIRCLE THING,
AND I WAS LIKE, OH! WHOOPSY.
MELROSE DEALS WITH
THE WIN ABOUT THE WAY
MELROSE DEALS WITH EVERYTHING--
SHE FREAKS OUT.
>> I'M PRETTY HARD ON MYSELF,
BUT FOR THIS, LIKE,
I DESERVE IT.
(crying) YOU HAVE TO BE...
PERFECT TO WIN THESE THINGS,
AND IT'S... FRUSTRATING.
>> HOW CAN YOU GET UPSET,
THOUGH?
LIKE, I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW YOU CAN GET SO UPSET.
>> MELROSE--
I THINK SHE STARTS CRYING.
SHE'S, LIKE,
MAD ABOUT NOT WINNING.
SHE'S USED TO WINNING EVERYTHING
AND SHE'S JUST A SORE LOSER.
>> I'M NOT PISSED AT EUGENA
OR THE OTHER GIRLS.
I'M MAD AT MYSELF.
I JUST HATE THAT
WE ONLY GET ONE CHANCE,
AND I JUST GET
REALLY FRUSTRATED.
I'M JUST LIKE...
I'M TRYING MY BEST.
DANCING IS, LIKE, MY SOUL.
IT'S MY PASSION, AND I JUST...
HATE THAT WE'RE CRITIQUED ON
IT.
>> PRESENTS! OH, OPEN THEM!
>> WHICH ONE'S MINE?
>> THAT WOULD BE AMANDA'S,
I'M GUESSING.
>> EUGENA WON
THE DANCE CHALLENGE TODAY,
AND SHE ACTUALLY PICKED ME
TO SHARE HER WIN.
AND I ACTUALLY EXPECTED HER
TO PICK CARIDEE,
SO IT WAS A NICE SURPRISE.
>> LOOK HOW CUTE THIS IS.
>> OH!
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> IS IT CUSTO?
>> I GUESS.
>> AMANDA OPENS HER GIFT FIRST,
AND IT'S A JACKET FROM CUSTO.
SO I OPEN MY GIFTS,
AND IT'S ALSO A JACKET
AND A SHIRT FROM CUSTO AS WELL.
>> OH, MY GOD,
LOOK AT THE BACK OF THIS!
>> WOW!
>> LOOK AT THIS!
EUGENA, THIS HAS TO BE
THE COOLEST JACKET EVER.
>> CARIDEE--
SHE'S SO MUCH TO DEAL WITH,
AND IT'S JUST REALLY HARD FOR ME
TO DEAL WITH AT THIS POINT
IN THE COMPETITION,
BUT YOU JUST DON'T
HAVE TO LIKE EVERYBODY.
THAT IS SO CUTE.
>> I'M OVER MELROSE.
I KNOW SHE HAS A PROBLEM
WITH NOT WINNING
AND SHE'S GETS REALLY MAD
IF SHE DOESN'T WIN,
AND I KNOW, YOU KNOW,
SHE'LL LASH OUT
IF SHE DIDN'T WIN.
>> THE ATTITUDES
ARE A LITTLE DIVA THESE DAYS.
I'M JUST OVERALL OVER CARIDEE.
LIKE, I BETTER WIN
THIS COMPETITION.
♪♪
>> (singsong voice) TYRA MAIL.
>> (singsong voice) TYRA MAIL!
>> "WILL YOU DROWN
WHEN FACED WITH
YOUR OWN COMPETITION?
LET'S SEE WHICH GIRL WILL SINK
WHEN SHE SEES YOU
FLOATING TO THE TOP."
I TOLD YOU WE'LL BE IN SHARKS.
>> IN SHARKS?
(laughs)
>> "WILL YOU DROWN
WHEN FACED WITH
YOUR OWN COMPETITION?"
>> THESE TYRA MAILS ARE GETTING
MORE AND MORE VAGUE.
♪♪
>> HOLA!
>> WE HAVE WALKED DOWN
SUCH A LONG ROAD,
WE TRAVELED ACROSS THE WORLD,
AND WE'RE DOWN TO FOUR GIRLS.
IT'S GETTING DOWN TO THE END,
SO TODAY
I HAD TO BRING SOMEBODY
TO HELP BRING THAT COMPETITION
TO THAT FINAL LEVEL.
>> OW!
>> YES?
>> ALL RIGHT, COME ON OUT!
(drumroll)
>> (cheering)
>> MWAH!
>> OH, WHATEVER.
>> NO, THAT WAS LUSCIOUS.
>> IT'S HUGE TO HAVE TYRA
BE HERE TODAY.
I MEAN, SHE'S HELPING US
WITH OUR CAREERS.
IT MEANS A LOT.
>> I AM GOING TO BE HERE TODAY
TO GUIDE YOU ALL ON SET
IN YOUR PHOTO SHOOT,
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT TO ME
BECAUSE I WANNA SEE HOW YOU WORK
WITH A PHOTOGRAPHER,
AND I ALSO WANNA SEE
WHAT I CAN GET OUT OF YOU
BY COACHING YOU.
I USED TO DO THIS A LOT--
SEASON 1 AND SEASON 2
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
AND I ACTUALLY REALLY MISS
COACHING MY GIRLS.
UH, NO, NO.
(grunts)
SO TODAY YOU'RE GOING TO BE
FLOATING ON WATER...
(laughter)
>> FLOATING ON YOUR BACK,
SO HOPEFULLY
YOU KNOW HOW TO SWIM.
>> OH!
>> I'M JUST THINKING,
OH, GOD, NO CHLORINE.
MY HAIR IS GONNA TURN GREEN.
(laughs)
>> YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE
WORKING BY YOURSELVES TODAY.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE PAIRING UP.
CARIDEE AND AMANDA,
POSING TOGETHER TODAY...
>> (laughs)
>> AND EUGENA AND MELROSE.
>> I KNEW IT.
I KNEW I WAS GONNA BE
WITH MELROSE.
I DON'T KNOW IF
I'M HAPPY OR NOT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW GOOD SHE IS
WITH TRYING TO COMMUNICATE
WITH ME, BECAUSE MELROSE IS
KIND OF SELFISH AND SHE
ONLY LOOKS OUT FOR HERSELF.
>> YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA LOOK LIKE
ETHEREAL NYMPHS,
SO WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU
EXTRA LONG HAIR
AND FLOWY FABRIC.
IT'S GONNA BE A GORGEOUS SHOT.
>> SO YOU READY
FOR HAIR AND MAKEUP?
>> YES!
>> ALL RIGHT, GET GOING!
>> I KNOW, BUT I DON'T WANT
ANY GLUE ON MY BRAID.
>> IT LOOKS REAL.
>> SO FOR FACE, SUTAN,
I WANT COVERAGE ON THE--
ON THE--ON THE BASE.
WATERPROOF MASCARA, OF COURSE,
'CAUSE WATER AND CHLORINE
IS GONNA GET ALL IN THEIR EYES.
SORRY.
YOU KNOW WHAT
THE SECRET TO FLOATING IS?
AN ARCHED BACK.
>> ARCHED BACK.
>> ARE YOU READY?
WALK DOWN THERE.
OH!
HOW DOES IT FEEL TO BE IN WATER
IN EVENING GOWNS?
>> (chuckles)
>> OOH, IT'S COLD!
>> I WANT YOU GUYS
TO DO DIFFERENT TYPES
OF CONFIGURATIONS--
HEAD INTO SHOULDER,
SHOULDER INTO...
>> AH.
>> LIKE THAT.
>> (laughs) THIS IS COLD!
>> TRY SHOOTING
"SPORTS ILLUSTRATED"
IN THE SNOW--
LAYING IN THE SNOW.
I DIDN'T DO IT,
BUT OTHER MODELS DID.
(laughter)
>> MELROSE AND I GO FIRST,
AND WE GET INTO THE POOL
AND THE POOL
IS FREEZING, FREEZING COLD
LIKE ICE WATER.
>> I LOVE HER JAW. SHE'S LIKE...
(imitates teeth chattering)
>> I HATE COLD WATER.
>> (screaming)
>> ¿DóNDE QUIERES LA...?
>> (speaking Spanish)
>> YOU WANT THEM HERE?
OKAY, AND I WANT THEM, UM,
CABEZA A CABEZA
OR--OR SIDE TO SIDE OR EVEN
HOLDING EACH OTHER'S HANDS...
LAS MANOS A LAS MANOS.
HEY, THEY'RE GONNA LET YOU GO
ON THE COUNT OF THREE.
UNO, DOS, TRES.
>> OKAY, COME OUT.
>> OUT, OUT, OUT! NICE!
OOPS, YOU LOST IT
WHEN HE LET YOU GO, EUGENA.
YOU LOST IT WHEN HE LET YOU GO.
PICK UP AGAIN.
AND IT'S OKAY TO TELL
THE PHOTOGRAPHER, YOU KNOW,
I NEED TO COME BACK UP AGAIN.
I NEED A BREAK.
THAT'S OKAY.
>> I THINK I'M GOOD IN WATER,
BUT I THINK THAT EUGENA'S
STRUGGLING A LITTLE BIT.
YOU KNOW, CAN'T REALLY
GET THE FLOAT ON.
>> AND ALSO MAKE SURE
YOU WATCH YOUR FOREHEADS,
'CAUSE SOMETIMES WHEN YOU MODEL
AND YOU GO BACKWARDS,
WE TEND TO, LIKE...
>> OH, YEAH.
>> LIKE, WRINKLE OUR FOREHEADS.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT'S INTERESTING--
DON'T THESE TWO GIRLS
HATE EACH OTHER?
>> REALLY?
>> AND IT DOESN'T HURT
TO PLAY WITH YOUR HAIR SOMETIMES
AND, LIKE, PULL IT UPWARD
AND PULL IT, LIKE,
SO THAT IT'S--
'CAUSE IT'S SINKING SOMETIMES.
AS A MODEL,
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO CORRECT IT
WHILE YOU'RE GOING.
YOU GUYS, WATCH YOUR HANDS.
KEEP 'EM REALLY SOFT.
>> (speaking Spanish)
>> SO LIKE THIS.
NICE.
>> MELROSE WAS GREAT FOR ME.
SHE WORKED GOOD INTO THE WATER
WITH THE SPECIAL, SOFT FACE.
>> AND IT LOOKS BEST
WHEN YOU GUYS LOOK LIKE
YOU LOVE EACH OTHER,
YOU'RE LIKE SISTERS.
>> YEAH, THAT'S GOOD.
>> I LIKE THAT THE BLACK
AND THE BLONDE HAIR IS MIXING.
>> THEY'RE ALL PRETTY.
>> THERE YOU GO.
HOP BACK UP, EUGENA.
MELROSE, DON'T LOOK AT
THE PHOTOGRAPHER ALL THE TIME.
>> WE HAD TO FLOAT AND ACT LIKE
LITTLE ANGELS IN THE WATER.
I COULDN'T MOVE.
I COULDN'T FLOAT.
IT WAS COLD, I WAS SHIVERING,
AND HOPEFULLY I DIDN'T LOOK LIKE
I WAS A DEAD FISH
UP IN THAT COLD WATER.
>> YES. COME ON.
>> ARCH THE BACKS.
EUGENA, COME BACK UP AND FLOAT.
>> TODAY WAS
A TYPICAL EUGENA SHOOT--
FLAT, BORING, AND IT LOOKED LIKE
SHE WAS DROWNING IN THE WATER.
>> OKAY, YOU GUYS ARE DONE.
>> CAREFUL.
>> YOU OKAY THERE?
>> MY JAWS WERE CHATTERING.
I JUST COULDN'T CONTROL MYSELF.
>> IS THAT THE HARDEST SHOOT
SO FAR?
>> YES, THE HARDEST SHOOT.
>> HARDEST ONE SO FAR?
>> YEAH.
I WAS FREEZING AND SHIVERING
BUT TRYING NOT
TO COMPLAIN ABOUT IT
BECAUSE WE'RE COMPETING HERE.
I NEED A HOT SHOWER.
(teeth chattering)
>> OH, I GET TO SEE
WHAT I HAVE TO LOOK FORWARD TO.
>> YOU WAIT, AMANDA.
>> I-I--NO, I'M--I'M AWFUL
AT COLD WATER.
I KNOW I'M GONNA BE A BABY.
>> GET READY TO CRY
A COUPLE TIMES.
>> GOD!
>> YOU WERE CRYING?
>> ALMOST.
(teeth chattering)
>> I NEVER WANNA DO THAT
EVER AGAIN.
>> ARE WE READY?
>> YEAH.
>> DID HE TELL YOU?
>> YES.
>> ETHEREAL ANGELS.
HANDS CLOSE TO THE FACE.
LET'S GO!
SO GO OVER THERE.
Sí, AMANDA!
BUENO!
>> I DON'T KNOW
WHAT KIND OF "BUENO"
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT,
BUT THIS IS NO BUENO.
>> GETTING IN THE WATER
WAS ABSOLUTELY COLD.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
IT'S ALWAYS A SHOCK
WHEN YOU GET INTO WATER,
BUT THIS WAS UNBELIEVABLY COLD.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I-I HAD TO DO
WHAT I HAD TO DO.
>> AND REMEMBER,
COLD IS THERE....
>> MM-HMM.
>> BUT NOT HERE.
>> MNH-MNH.
>> OKAY? NOT HERE.
NOT ON YOUR FACE.
>> (speaking Spanish)
>> YOU GUYS ARE GOOD FLOATERS!
JUST LIKE THIS, THOUGH.
(grunting)
SOFT ARMS, RELAXED FACE.
YOUR ARM IS
TOO LIKE THIS, AMANDA.
YOU'RE LIKE THIS...
SOFT. YES!
OKAY, AMANDA,
YOU'RE LOOKING REALLY STIFF.
YOU JUST HAVE TO, LIKE,
NOT THINK ABOUT DROWNING.
>> OKAY.
>> OKAY?
>> IS IT MY FACE THAT'S STIFF
OR MY BODY?
>> MM-HMM, YOUR FACE AND BODY.
>> AS FAR AS EXPERIENCE GOES,
AMANDA IS THE WEAKER MODEL
OUT OF ALL OF US.
I MEAN, SHE'S STILL YOUNG.
SHE'S NAIVE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT TRYING ANYMORE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT TRYING TO GET IT.
IT'S, LIKE, YOU HAVE TO HAVE IT.
>> THAT'S ACTUALLY PRETTY
IF YOU CAN KEEP THAT.
>> CAREFUL HERE.
>> RELAX.
>> AMANDA, YOUR RIGHT HAND--
WATCH THE HAND, WATCH THE HAND.
>> YEAH, HOLD YOURSELF.
>> OKAY, AMANDA, LOOKING.
>> OKAY, SORRY,
I WAS LOSING MY CONTACTS.
>> OKAY NOW?
>> YEAH.
>> OKAY.
>> IT'S REALLY COLD.
>> YES, REALLY.
BUT YOU FEEL SOMETHING STRANGE,
SAY IT, OKAY?
>> MM-HMM.
>> OKAY, GIRLS, LET'S DO IT.
>> CARIDEE, YOU'RE FROM FARGO!
COME ON!
>> I FORGOT.
>> THIS IS
REAL, REAL MODELING, GUYS,
BEING COLD AS HECK.
>> THERE'S A POINT WHERE MY BODY
JUST LITERALLY TAKES OVER,
AND, LIKE, I FEEL LIKE MY SKIN
AND EVERYTHING IS JUST, LIKE,
PINS AND NEEDLES.
>> TOUCH YOUR HAIR.
PUT IT UNDERNEATH IN THE HAIR.
OH, THIS IS PRETTY, GIRLS!
OKAY, OKAY, GO!
LA LA LA LA LA! GET THE SHOT!
GET THE SHOT! GET THE SHOT!
>> BUT WHEN THE CAMERA
GOT ON ME, YOU KNOW,
I TRIED TO JUST
SHAKE THOSE SHIVERS AWAY
AND NOT LET IT SHOW IN MY FACE,
BUT IT WAS OBVIOUSLY COLD.
>> OUT.
>> CAN I HAVE A BREAK?
>> ¿UNO MOMENTO?
>> YEAH.
>> IT WAS SO COLD, YOUR BREATH
WAS LITERALLY BEING TAKEN AWAY.
YOU KNOW, I WAS JUST, LIKE,
OKAY, CONCENTRATE.
(exhales) BREATHE, BREATHE,
BREATHE.
>> CARIDEE ACTUALLY HAD TO STOP
BECAUSE SHE WAS SO COLD,
THAT SHE WAS KINDA CONVULSING.
>> OKAY?
>> AS A MODEL,
YOU NEED TO TELL PEOPLE
WHEN YOU'RE PAST YOUR LIMIT.
IT WASN'T JUST THAT
SHE WAS COLD.
HER TEETH WERE CHATTERING.
SHE HAD REACHED THE MOMENT
OF HYPOTHERMIA.
>> HOW'S THE--
HOW ARE THE PICTURES, BABY?
>> (chuckles) THEY LOOK GOOD.
>> ARE THEY BETTER?
AM I GETTING GOOD AGAIN?
>> YOU HAVE TO LISTEN
TO YOUR BODY,
AND YOU HAVE TO TELL US, OKAY?
>> OKAY.
>> BECAUSE ALL WE KNOW IS
GO, GO, GO, GO.
GO, GO, GO, GO, GO.
BUT YOU HAVE TO TELL US "NO."
>> UH-HUH, UH-HUH.
>> CARIDEE WAS FREEZING COLD--
LIKE THE REST OF US--
BUT SHE'S DRAMATIC
TO THE POINT WHERE IT'S--
IT NEEDS ATTENTION RIGHT NOW.
>> DO YOU WANT AMANDA
TO DO SOME SINGLES?
BECAUSE SHE'S--FEELS BETTER?
>> BUT IT'S JUST
GONNA BE AMANDA ONLY.
>> HEY, I'LL GO MORE.
>> ALL RIGHT, JUST GET 50 MORE.
>> OKAY.
>> SO IN ALL FAIRNESS TO AMANDA,
THERE WERE ABOUT 50 FRAMES LEFT
IN THE PHOTO SHOOT,
SO AMANDA DID
THE LAST 50 FRAMES ALONE.
>> COME BACK THIS WAY.
THAT'S SO PRETTY, ON THE SIDE.
>> THAT'S--THAT'S...
COME ON, AMANDA.
>> IF AMANDA DOES
GIVE US SOMETHING AMAZING,
WE'LL DIGITALLY COMPOSITE
HER BEST SHOT IN
WITH ONE OF THE PHOTOGRAPHS
THAT CARIDEE HAD DONE EARLIER.
>> SOFT, SOFTER. SOFTER ARMS.
NICE. HOLD IT, HOLD IT.
JUST LIKE THAT. JUST LIKE THAT.
HOLD IT BACK.
OKAY, GOT IT! GIVE ME FIVE!
>> (grunts)
>> YOU WENT ABOVE AND BEYOND.
>> I'M ALWAYS NERVOUS
ABOUT PANEL, BUT TYRA SAID,
"NO, YOU'RE NOT GETTING BACK
IN THE WATER."
I HOPE IT DOESN'T AFFECT JUDGING
BECAUSE I COULDN'T HELP
HOW MY BODY REACTED, BUT I--
WHEN IT CAME TO THE PICTURES,
I DID MY BEST
NOT TO LET IT SHOW.
♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> HUH.
>> I WONDER WHAT IT SAYS.
>> WHAT DOES IT SAY?
>> "TOMORROW
YOU WILL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY THREE WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> WE GOT ANOTHER
ELIMINATION TYRA MAIL,
AND IT MEANS
SOMEBODY'S GOING HOME.
SO I JUST HOPE IT'S NOT ME
OR ANYBODY I LIKE,
BUT WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> AT OUR FLAMENCO DANCE,
I MESSED UP.
I WAS SO DISAPPOINTED IN MYSELF
BECAUSE I WAS PRACTICING SO WELL
AND THEN I SCREWED UP
MY FOOTWORK.
BUT I KNOW I CAN DO BETTER.
I KNOW I CAN ONLY
GO UP FROM HERE.
>> MY DRESS--IT WAS, LIKE,
WRAPPING ALL AROUND MY LEGS,
THAT WAS, LIKE,
THE HARDEST SHOOT
THAT WE'VE HAD.
>> I DON'T FEEL GOOD.
MY THROAT'S SORE.
>> CARIDEE HAD TO BE
PULLED OUT THE WATER BECAUSE
SHE WAS SHAKING AND SHIVERING
A LITTLE TOO MUCH.
SO SHE DIDN'T GET TO FINISH
HER PHOTO SHOOT.
I HEARD THAT AMANDA
DIDN'T DO SO WELL
BECAUSE SHE WAS
LOOKING AWKWARD AS USUAL.
>> THE PARAMEDICS CAME
AND STARTED PUTTING THINGS
HERE AND THERE.
I DID QUIT.
I HARDLY FELT THE WATER,
BUT IT'S JUST...
MY BODY COULDN'T HANDLE IT.
>> THE WATER WAS FREEZING.
>> IT'S LIKE, WE'RE REALLY
GETTING NARROWED DOWN,
AND I STILL AM, LIKE,
IN THE COMPETITION.
BUT I'M REALLY WORRIED
ABOUT THIS, UH, PANEL
BECAUSE SO FEW GIRLS,
YOU NEED TO DO GOOD
AND I DID NOT DO GOOD.
SO I DON'T WANT
TO GET MY HOPES UP TOO HIGH,
BUT I REALLY WANT THIS.
♪♪
>> WELL, WE'RE BACK
FOR ANOTHER ELIMINATION.
IT'S GETTING TIGHTER AND TIGHTER
AND TIGHTER, BUT Y'ALL ARE
THE TOP FOUR FINEST...
CHICKS.
>> (laughs)
>> IS THAT WHAT
YOU REALLY WANTED TO SAY?
>> NO, I WANTED TO SAY
"BITCHES."
(laughter)
>> AND YOU ALL KNOW ABOUT
OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODELING AGENCIES IN THE WORLD--
ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT...
AND NOT 3-PAGE, 4-PAGE, 5 PAGES,
BUT SIX PAGES AND A COVER
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR ME
TO INTRODUCE YOU TO THE JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
AND THE LUSCIOUS, DIVINE,
MAKES ME WEAK,
RUNWAY COACH EXTRAORDINAIRE...
>> (laughs)
>> MISS J. ALEXANDER,
AND OUR FASHION ICON,
MISS TWIGGY.
>> HELLO, GIRLIES. (chuckles)
>> HI!
>> AND DAVID RUIZ,
THE PHOTOGRAPHER THAT SHOT YOU,
AND Y'ALL WAS DROWNING.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND AFTER THAT
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE
AND WILL DETERMINE
WHO IS GOING HOME.
AND MELROSE AND EUGENA,
YOU'RE FIRST.
>> (laughs)
>> ALL RIGHT, GIRLS,
SO THIS WEEK YOU LEARNED ABOUT
WORKING WITH A PARTNER.
IN THE MODELING WORLD,
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO HAVE
ANOTHER MODEL IN A PICTURE
OR WORK WITH HER ON A RUNWAY
OR IN A COMMERCIAL.
AND A LOT OF MODELS SAY,
"I'M SORRY, I DON'T DO DOUBLES."
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
HOW TO WORK WITH SOMEBODY ELSE,
SO THAT'S WHAT YOU DID ALL WEEK.
AND THE FIRST THING YOU HAD
TO DO WAS DANCE FLAMENCO,
AND YOU WERE GETTING
PHOTOGRAPHED.
SO, MELROSE,
WE'RE GONNA START WITH YOU.
>> OKAY.
>> OOH.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE REALLY INTO IT, ACTUALLY.
I LOVE THE EYES DOWN.
YOU LOOK VERY SPANISH.
I LOVE THE ARM UP.
>> NEXT IS EUGENA,
AND ACTUALLY
YOU WERE THE CHALLENGE WINNER,
SO CONGRATULATIONS.
I HEARD YOU ROCKED IT.
>> CAN YOU TWO
DO A LITTLE DANCE NUMBER
LIKE WHAT YOU WERE TOLD TO DO?
♪♪
>> SO YOU WERE DANCING
WITH ONE ANOTHER.
WE HAVE TWO PHOTOGRAPHERS
OVER HERE.
WHAT DID YOU DO
THAT WAS DIRECTED AT US
OR AT THE JUDGING TABLE
THAT WAS SPECIFIC
TO A PHOTOGRAPH?
IT'S ALL IN THE FACE, GUYS.
>> ALL RIGHT,
YOU ALL HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
FLOATING ON YOUR BACKS,
AND I COACHED YOU THROUGH IT.
YOU READY TO SEE YOUR BEST SHOT?
>> WOW. BEAUTIFUL.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE IT SHOULD BE ON
THE SISTINE CHAPEL.
>> YOU GUYS LOOK LIKE MERMAIDS.
IT'S LOVELY.
>> THE WHOLE ART OF A DOUBLE
IS TO SHARE THE FRAME,
BUT ALSO TO SHINE IN THE FRAME,
AND WHAT I LOVE ABOUT THIS IS
I LOOK AT BOTH OF YOU EQUALLY.
>> MELROSE,
YOU JUST SEEMED VERY CALM.
I KNEW YOU WERE COLD,
BUT WHEN YOU WERE SHOOTING
I DIDN'T FEEL
THAT YOU WERE COLD.
AND IN GOING THROUGH THE FILM,
THERE WERE SO MANY FACES--
TONS OF FACES TO CHOOSE FROM.
>> YEAH, GREAT.
GREAT FROM THE BEGINNING.
>> GOOD.
>> NOW, EUGENA,
ON THE OTHER HAND--
A LOT OF THE FILM, YOUR FACE WAS
KIND OF LIKE... (grunting)
AND YOU STILL HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH CONNECTING.
YOU'RE GETTING A LOT,
LOT BETTER, BUT YOU WERE
STRUGGLING WITH THE FLOATING.
ACTUALLY IN THIS SHOT,
YOU'RE NOT FLOATING.
YOUR FOOT'S ON THE GROUND.
>> IN THE BEGINNING, I WAS
TRYING REALLY HARD TO FLOAT,
BUT IT JUST WASN'T WORKING
SO IT WAS LIKE...
>> JUST KNOW THAT IF YOU'RE
NOT GETTING IT PERFECTLY--
TRY TO GET A COUPLE OF SHOTS
FLOATING, YOU START TO SINK,
KEEP THE FACE PRETTY.
>> EUGENA,
A LITTLE BIT AFRAID WITH WATER.
>> COLD WATER.
>> THANK YOU.
AMANDA AND CARIDEE.
WE'LL START WITH CARIDEE.
>> I LOVE THE MOVEMENT.
YOU REALLY LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE DANCING.
>> (singsong voice) FANTáSTICO!
>> (laughs)
>> AMANDA HAD TO DO FLAMENCO
AS WELL.
>> YES.
>> AMANDA. I LIKE THAT
YOU'RE NOT SCARED OF HIM--
>> YOUR LEG IS, LIKE,
OVER HIS LEG.
>> IF YOU HAVE A LOOK
AT THE PICTURE CLOSELY
AT THE BOTTOM,
IT LOOKS LIKE
YOUR OTHER LEG IS BROKEN.
LOOK AT HOW IT'S FACING.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO.
>> YEAH, BUT LOOK.
GO DOWN, DUDE.
>> (laughs)
>> OH.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
>> IT'S CONTORTIONIST.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS YOUR--
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS
YOUR LEFT FOOT IN THE FRONT--
>> HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
>> I DIDN'T KNOW
I COULD DO THAT. (laughs)
>> OH, MY GOD!
THAT DOESN'T HURT?
OH!
UGH!
>> IT'S ALMOST LOOKS
LIKE A HORROR MOVIE.
>> SO NOW CAN YOU TWO
DO US A FAVOR HERE
AND DEMONSTRATE
WHAT YOU WERE TAUGHT,
SO WE CAN SEE?
♪♪
(castanets clicking)
>> OH.
>> (both laugh)
>> AMANDA,
I FELT YOUR EMBARRASSMENT
WHEN CARIDEE DECIDED
TO FLIP OVER
AND DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
>> PLAY IT OFF.
>> YOU'RE NOT EXPECTED TO BE
A PROFESSIONAL FLAMENCO DANCER,
BUT YOU ARE EXPECTED
TO LOOK LIKE ONE IN THE PHOTO.
I REMEMBER
VICTORIA'S SECRET FASHION SHOW.
THEY SAID, "YOU KNOW WHAT, TYRA?
WE'RE GONNA HAVE YOU DO
FLAMENCO DANCING."
>> OH, I SAW THAT.
>> YES.
AND THEY TOLD ME
THAT I WAS GONNA DO THIS, LIKE,
A COUPLE HOURS BEFORE THE SHOW.
SO I WORK
WITH THIS TOP FLAMENCO DANCER,
AND HE TEACHES ME
ALL THESE MOVES.
THAT FASHION SHOW STARTED.
EVERY MOVE WENT OUT OF MY HEAD,
AND I JUST AD-LIBBED IT
AND JUST WENT WITH IT.
AND I'M SURE MY TEACHER WAS
IN THE AUDIENCE LIKE,
"WHAT THE HELL IS SHE DOING?"
BUT EVERYBODY ELSE
IN THE AUDIENCE WAS LIKE,
"BRAVO! OH, MY GOSH!"
>> IF YOU'RE STILL DANCING,
AND SHE THROWS YOU OFF...
FOR EXAMPLE,
JUST--JUST--
>> I WANNA DANCE WITH YOU,
MISS J.
LET'S DANCE.
>> HUH?
>> LET'S DANCE.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW... (laughs)
THIS WAS AN INVITATION TO DANCE.
>> OH, YES, IT WAS.
>> I WAS EXPLAINING--
OKAY, 'CAUSE I'VE NEVER DONE--
OKAY.
>> AH!
>> WHOO!
>> THERE YOU GO!
>> (laughs)
>> AND YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENED?
>> GIRL EVEN LOST HER SLIPPERS.
>> THIS CAME OFF.
>> BUT SHE KEPT GOING.
>> BUT WE KEPT GOING.
AND I'M THINKING,
"DAMN, MY SHOE CAME OFF.
BUT YOU GOTTA KEEP GOING."
ALL RIGHT.
>> (laughing)
>> ALL RIGHT.
YOU ALL HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> YOU DO LOOK LIKE
WATER NYMPHS.
IT'S LOVELY.
>> THIS IS MY FAVORITE.
>> AND THAT LOOKS
ACTUALLY LIKE, AGAIN,
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S FROM
A VERY HIGH-FASHION MAGAZINE.
>> AND ACTUALLY, AMANDA,
YOU'VE GOT
A VERY PRETTY FACE HERE,
BUT I--IT'S--I WANT TO SEE
JUST SOMETHING MORE.
I DO FEEL THAT
YOU'RE JUST THERE.
>> SO ACTUALLY,
YOUR FACE IS ANOTHER FACE
STOLEN FROM ANOTHER SHOT.
BUT I WAS VERY IMPRESSED
WITH YOU, AMANDA,
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T KNOW
HOW TO FLOAT,
BUT YOU TOOK A COUPLE OF NOTES,
AND THEN BECAME SOMEONE
THAT KNEW HOW TO FLOAT.
BUT YOUR ISSUE IS
YOUR HANDS AND YOUR ELBOWS.
IT'S LIKE A SCARECROW.
LIKE, YOU PUT 'EM OUT HERE,
AND YOU GO LIKE THIS,
AND YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW AWKWARD YOUR HANDS ARE.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU REALLY HAVE TO DO
IN THE MIRROR,
AND LOOK AT MAGAZINES,
AND LOOK AT MODELS' HANDS.
MODELS' HANDS AREN'T LIKE THAT,
AND THEIR ELBOWS
AREN'T LIKE THAT.
>> JUST--
JUST WHAT ABOUT, UH, YOUR BODY?
CONTROL YOUR BODY.
HOLD YOUR BODY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
UM, I WAS IMPRESSED
WITH CARIDEE,
BECAUSE CARIDEE--SHE KIND OF
DIDN'T STOP FLOATING.
EVEN THOUGH I KNEW YOU WERE
HAVING A REALLY HARD TIME
AND SHIVERING,
I NEVER SAW ONE FRAME
WHERE YOU LOOKED COLD--
NOT ONE FRAME.
>> HOW WAS IT FOR YOU, CARI?
>> UM, IT WAS REALLY COLD--
REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY COLD FOR ME.
AT ONE POINT,
MY WHOLE BODY JUST KIND OF
FREAKED OUT.
BUT WHEN IT CAME TO TIME,
TAKING THE PICTURES--
I WASN'T COLD.
LIKE, I-I TRIED MY HARDEST
NOT TO LET IT SHOW.
>> THAT WAS VERY IMPRESSIVE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
AS A MODEL,
YOU HAVE TO KNOW YOUR LIMITS,
AND YOU HAVE TO KNOW THAT
IF YOU'RE GETTING SICK
AND YOUR BODY
IS FEELING A CERTAIN WAY,
THAT YOU HAVE TO STEP AWAY
FROM THE SITUATION.
>> YOU'D NEVER KNOW IT.
>> YEAH.
>> ALL RIGHT,
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR US JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I'LL ANNOUNCE WHO'S ELIMINATED.
♪♪
>> SO NOW IT'S TIME TO DECIDE
WHO'S GOING HOME.
MELROSE.
>> MELROSE,
WHO SEEMS TO BE ABLE
TO DO NO WRONG...
>> (laughs)
>> BUT THERE IS SOMETHING
ABOUT MELROSE WHICH,
FOR SOME REASON, IRKS ME.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE HAT TODAY?
>> THE HAT... IT'S THAT
SHE'S TRYING TOO HARD FOR ME.
SHE KNOWS
WHAT SHE'S MEANT TO SAY,
WHAT SHE'S MEANT TO DO,
AND TEN OUT OF TEN FOR THAT.
BUT WHETHER SHE'S NATURAL AT IT,
WHETHER IT JUST
COMES OUT OF HER SKIN,
I DON'T KNOW.
>> SHE'S CONTINUALLY DELIVERED
GREAT PHOTOGRAPHS.
SHE HASN'T GOT AS UNIQUE
A LOOK AS AMANDA,
BUT I THINK SHE'S GOT
ALL THE OTHER ELEMENTS.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
>> MELROSE WAS SHOCKING,
HOW WELL SHE DID IN THE POOL.
SHE REALLY WAS.
AND I'M SURE
SHE TURNED IT UP A NOTCH
'CAUSE I WAS THERE,
BUT SHE TRIED TO IMPRESS ME,
AND SHE DID.
EUGENA.
>> THERE'S STILL AN ELEMENT
ABOUT EUGENA THAT WORRIES ME--
THAT--THAT WITHDRAWN QUALITY.
>> I SAW HER ELEGANT.
I SAW HER BEAUTY,
BUT A LITTLE DRY.
>> DRY.
>> IT WAS A STRUGGLE FOR ME
WITH EUGENA,
UM, AT THE PHOTO SHOOT.
SHE SEEMS TO, LIKE,
GIVE UP, LIKE,
ALMOST LIKE SHE'S NOT CARING.
I THINK EUGENA IS STILL HERE
BECAUSE OF HER POTENTIAL--
NOT BECAUSE OF WHAT
SHE'S DELIVERING, BUT, LIKE,
IT'S BECAUSE OF WHAT WE SEE.
CARIDEE.
>> THIS IS A GREAT PHOTOGRAPH
OF CARIDEE.
DESPITE THE FACT SHE SUFFERED,
IT JUST SHOWS THAT CARIDEE
IS CAPABLE OF TAKING
A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE.
>> ESPECIALLY
AS WE NOW KNOW THAT
SHE WAS GETTING HYPOTHERMIA.
YOU'D NEVER READ IT IN HER FACE.
SHE'S TONED DOWN
THE MANIC SIDE OF HERSELF.
>> YOU KNOW,
I'M STILL NERVOUS ABOUT CARIDEE,
BECAUSE WE'RE FEELING
THIS HIGH-MAINTENANCE THING
ABOUT HER.
SHE NEEDS A LOT OF ATTENTION,
AND THAT AMOUNT OF ATTENTION
IS SOMETHING THAT,
YEAH, TOP MODEL GETS.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE BECOMING
A TOP MODEL,
YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE
THAT HIGH MAINTENANCE.
>> WITH CARIDEE,
IT'S ALL ABOUT ME,
ME, ME, ME, ME, ME, ME, ME, ME.
>> AMANDA.
>> SHE HAS NO COORDINATION,
BUT YOU LOOK AT HER FACE
IN PHOTOGRAPHS,
AND THE CAMERA LOVES HER.
AND - AND SHE ALSO LOOKS VERY
NEW.
>> AMANDA IS--
HAS AN INSPIRATIONAL FACE.
>> MM.
>> IT'S THE FACE OF--
OF FASHION TODAY.
>> IT DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE ANYBODY ELSE,
WHICH I THINKS VERY IMPORTANT.
>> BODY IS A DISASTER.
>> I KNOW.
SO IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
CAN I PICK HER HEAD
AND HER BODY,
AND NOT HER ARMS AND LEGS?
>> NO, YOU CAN'T.
>> AMANDA--
I THINK SHE NEEDS, UH,
TO KNOW HER BODY.
I THINK IT'S TOO JUNG.
>> TOO YOUNG?
>> YEAH.
>> "TOO JUNG."
(laughs) I LOVE THAT.
"TOO JUNG."
>> YEAH.
>> WE'VE REACHED A DECISION.
♪♪
>> THIS IS WHEN THE COMPETITION
STARTS GETTING REALLY TOUGH.
FOUR GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
AND I ONLY HAVE THREE PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE THREE OF YOU THAT
WILL STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
MELROSE.
>> (mouths words)
>> CONGRATULATIONS, MELROSE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE JUDGES THINK THAT
YOU'RE SUCH A STRONG MODEL,
BUT THEY DON'T FEEL LIKE
THEY'VE SEEN
THE REAL MELROSE YET.
SO TAKE DOWN THE VENEER,
AND LET'S JUST SEE THE REAL YOU.
>> OKAY.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
>> EUGENA.
>> EUGENA, YOU ARE HERE
BY THE SKIN OF YOUR TEETH,
MISS LADY.
BUT WHAT THE JUDGES SEE
IS SOMEBODY
THAT IS PUSHING FORWARD
AND THAT IS IMPROVING
FROM WEEK TO WEEK.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (mouths words)
>> WILL CARIDEE AND AMANDA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
>> I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL CALL ONLY ONE NAME,
AND THE GIRL
THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
YOU BOTH STAND BEFORE ME,
AND AS I LOOK AT YOU,
YOU BOTH HAVE STRONG POTENTIAL.
YOUR LOOK--
I'M LOOKING AT AMANDA,
AND I'M LIKE,
"WHOA, THAT'S A MODEL."
I'M LOOKING AT CARIDEE LIKE,
AMANDA, YOU STAND BEFORE ME
WITH AN EDGY, HIGH-FASHION LOOK,
A LOOK THAT EXCITES THE JUDGES.
AND THE JUDGES
LOOK AT YOUR PICTURES
FROM WEEK TO WEEK
AND SAY, "WOW.
THOSE ARE BEAUTIFUL PICTURES,
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING
A LITTLE AWKWARD ABOUT THEM."
THEY ALSO LOOK AT PERSONALITY,
AND THE JUDGES SAY,
"SHE'S SWEET AND SHE'S ENGAGING,
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT MIGHT BE
A LITTLE BIT TOO SOFT,
A LITTLE BIT TOO MEEK,
MAYBE."
AND THERE'S YOU, CARIDEE,
THE GIRL WITH
ALL THE BUBBLING PERSONALITY.
SOMETIMES IT BUBBLES OVER
SO MUCH THAT
IT SPILLS AND IT FLOODS.
BUT SOME OF THE JUDGES SAY,
THIS IS A FASHION INDUSTRY.
IT'S GONNA BE COLD.
SWIMSUITS ARE SHOT
IN THE WINTER,
WHEN IT'S FREEZING.
AND BIG HEAVY COATS
ARE SHOT IN THE SUMMER,
WHEN IT'S BURNING UP.
AND THEY DON'T THINK
THAT YOU CAN HANDLE THAT.
SO WHO GOES HOME?
THE GIRL WITH THE EDGY LOOKS
THAT'S AWKWARD?
OR THE GIRL
WITH THE CLASSIC LOOKS,
BUT MAYBE NOT THE STRENGTH?
>> CONGRATULATIONS, CARIDEE.
♪♪
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (whispers) OKAY.
>> YOU KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE A WEAKNESS WITH COLD.
>> MM-HMM.
>> YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THAT DOESN'T COST
THE CLIENT MONEY.
I'M HERE TO DELIVER
THE TOUGH NEWS
ABOUT THIS DEMANDING BUSINESS,
BUT YOU HAVE TO PROTECT YOURSELF
AT THE SAME TIME.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> MISS AMANDA.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
(normal voice) IT'S ALWAYS HARD
WHEN SOMETHING GOOD ENDS,
AND THIS WAS DEFINITELY
SOMETHING GOOD FOR ME.
IT'S OVER.
AND I WANTED TO BE
IN THE FINAL TWO
JUST TO EXPERIENCE IT ALL,
AND I WANTED TO WIN,
BUT I MEAN,
IT WAS GREAT TO MAKE IT
TO THE FINAL FOUR.
IT WAS A LOT OF FUN.
IT'S SOMETHING
I WON'T EVER FORGET.
THAT CAN NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
IT'S HARD TO PACK UP YOUR THINGS
AND KNOW TOMORROW--
IT'LL JUST BE A REGULAR DAY.
IT'S JUST WEIRD.
♪♪
>> I THINK I DID WANT THIS
MORE THAN MY SISTER.
I THINK I WANTED IT MORE.
IT'S JUST HARD
TO LEAVE SOMETHING, YOU KNOW?
IT'S HARD.
THERE'S NOT REALLY A WAY
TO EXPLAIN HOW YOU FEEL.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE
I'M BREAKING UP
WITH "TOP MODEL,"
BUT I GOT BROKEN UP WITH.
(laughs)
♪♪